imagine if you got to play a
stormtrooper well that was topic number
one when Ashley cross and landed at
galaxy's edge to talk with the cast
we've seen cameos from a bunch of
celebrities like a storm troopers at
Sheeran Glenn Miller Miranda Daniel
Craig was a rumor for a little bit
well Daniel Craig was a storm trooper in
force awakens' I'll tighten those
restraints scavenger scum Stephen
Colbert is another celebra more to be
making a cameo but this marks the last
time we'll see the late Carrie Fisher in
a Star Wars movie we'll always be with
you no one's ever really gone I can't
talk about this film without talking
about Carrie Fisher is there a piece of
advice that she gave when he dies that
sticks out I remember you were telling
me one time she just tells you to break
her diet
laughs Jedi nose hungry as hell and she
said go to my trailer
Snickers Twix I mean Billie man we went
sour Wars the rise of Skywalker is the
final installment in the Skywalker saga
for this cast it's a bittersweet end
you're not famous falls into
people see you as a trio and it was
important in this one for me like that
we were together just as sure that
chemistry I'm beginning to feel a trio
was I not there I was the one in gold
[Music]